rules and the incentives and politics
are all screwed up companies are usually
competing trying to succeed in politics
parties are competing to benefit
themselves most of the people I talk to
they're just kind of thrown in the towel
saying I don't trust politicians and I
really don't want to do nothing about it
this is unacceptable
we have to change this what role do you
think universities and professors are
planned to send to a school to pay 50 to
70 grand a year knowing they're gonna
come out looking at rich people as bad
people this tremendous gap in wealth
capitalism haven't even any
responsibility for any of them you don't
think so how could you say that
competition delivers results to
customers in every industry we can't
just say here's what we're gonna do to
change the voting your question is are
they gonna let you do this we have a
choice voting in the state of Maine we
have read Tory's voting on the ballot in
Massachusetts free-market politics a
politics which delivers what healthy
free markets deliver that's catches that
makes sense to me more choice or voice
and better results so today I have two
special guests from you one is Michael
Porter which Michael Porter is like if
you go on Harvard campus and you'll walk
in Iran and the name Michael Porter
comes out Michael Porter is Elvis
Presley in Harvard because when I took
OPM everybody wanted to meet Michael
Porter for the entrepreneurs and the
business folks out there let me give the
proper introduction to him he wrote a
book called competitive strategy I
believe he's written 19 books
he's the bishop William Lawrence
University professor at Harvard
Forbes describes him as the most famous
and influential business professor who
ever lived that's Michael Porter now
let's talk about our other guest
Katherine Gayle who I had a chance to
get to know last night we had a
phenomenal conversation together prior
to doing this interview when I saw the
book the politics industry and it was
brought up to us to do this interview I
said let's look into this and then I
started looking at her story this is not
somebody this is she's got a very
interesting story it's almost an anomaly
because here's somebody who goes out
there and becomes the CEO and the
president
of a company family company that's been
around over over a century known a
quarter of billion dollars per year and
they recently went through a transaction
I was saying I want to say 2015 but then
throughout the process she gets inspired
to get involved in politics and
eventually eventually in 2010 she gets
nominated by President Barack Obama to
serve as member of the board of
directors of the overseas Private
Investment Corporation and was confirmed
by United States in October of 2011
Senate 2011 and I think she resigned in
2015 and then went back to the business
and all of that's led to their
relationship together they wrote a paper
together I want to say in 2017 which led
to this book so having said that Michael
Porter Katherine Gill thank you so much
for being a guest on that containment so
I have a question
you know Michael let's start off with
you so you when I read the preface in
the book to me you've always been a
business guy you've always been a
competition guy you were a UH you played
I think you played on the championing
tip of a Princeton golf and you were
somebody that played a lot of different
sports and you've always stuck to your
strategy side that side and I did we
hear a lot about politics but it was
very interesting for you to want to
partner I'm gonna want to write this
what inspired you to want to take the
take a look at competition in the world
of politics well what I discovered was
and with the help of Katherine was that
actually all the things I cared about
making America more competitive getting
the right policies in place stimulating
the advancement of our business business
sector all those things were being
shackled by failure of our politics
system we just couldn't get anything
done that was gonna drive our country to
the next level so really it was that
simple
and and how many similarities from the
moment you guys started working on it
competition wise because to me I see
differences but I'm curious to know for
somebody that like you you're the expert
you're a godfather of competition and
the topic of competition what
differences you see in the world of
business when it comes to competition
versus the world of politics when it
comes to competition it's it's kind of a
stunning
difference and in business competition
companies are usually competing you know
fairly and to try to succeed and to try
to advance and in politics the
competition is totally about the
competitors own interests the parties
the parties are competing to benefit
themselves and to advance their cause
really not to advance the public
interest not to make the country better
not to make our business environment
better so it's like a stunning
disconnect yeah and we'll go we'll go
deeper into that but Catherine I want to
go to you because the idea of this book
came from you and you approached Michael
Porter to want to work on this together
here you are going to Kellogg you know
you get you I think you got your MBA
from Kellogg if I'm not mistaken so
you're you're succeeding in business you
come from a great lineage of business
folks you're doing it for yourself
you're in Wisconsin you do what you're
doing
what what led you and drew into politics
I mean how did that happen for you you
know it's actually interesting it seems
like it's a disconnect but it really is
fundamentally my experience as a
business person as a CEO that makes any
of this possible so like you mentioned
before I was running this food
manufacturing company and that
experience gave me all the learnings
that I needed to do what I'm doing today
I mean as you know and so many of your
you know viewers will know business
really teaches innovation results
accountability and how to deliver those
and those are all the things that we
actually don't have in politics and the
lack of that is apparent to everybody I
mean and people really they may not say
oh we don't have innovation and results
and accountability but they say all the
time Washington is broken and and that's
what I thought at the same time I just
couldn't figure out why it was broken
like why was it so irrational how can
the country that created modern
democracy and free market enterprise you
know do such a poor job essentially of
both of those that there
becoming almost existentially at risk
and Michael could talk about more
details about her declining fortunes but
I'll just fast forward to light bulb
moment for me around this politics work
I was deeply concerned as a citizen as a
business leader because I saw the
policies that weren't getting
implemented but they didn't fully
understand and in 2013 when I was still
running my company I read this amazing
book by Mickey Edwards a former
Republican congressman and it's called
the parties versus the people and in
there he he says Washington isn't broken
it's doing what it's designed to do so
really as we figured out then we don't
have a politician problem we don't have
a policy problem we have a political
system problem the rules and the
incentives and politics are all screwed
up and we'll talk more about that later
so as I'm realizing this coincidentally
I'm starting a company strategy product
project with fortunately for us the
father of modern corporate strategy
Michael Porter and we're I'm trying to
figure out my food industry business
using the Five Forces while I was doing
that in the back of my head I kept
having this parallel analysis going on
oh my goodness this is exactly how the
politics industry works as well so it
was really running two analyses using
the Five Forces at the same time and I
found it to be illuminating and a real
clear way to say what's wrong but much
more importantly a clearer way to help
diagnose how we could fix it this is one
thing to know why it's wrong it's
another thing to figure out where would
we have the leverage to change it and so
that was the turning point I was all
into system system systems incentives
rules of the game and I couldn't unsee
so every time I saw what was going on in
Washington DC it immediately went back
to the analysis and I said oh we could
predict that this behavior which seems
irrational to those of us in business
and is totally counterproductive
certainly for the country
he's totally rational given the system
they're in so after I sold my company in
2015 I was working on changing this it's
changing the incentives but I felt that
businesspeople were missing in action
they were m.i.a
from the conversation and from the
leadership to make a difference
essentially they I believed felt that
politics was too irrational and they
couldn't do anything about it so I
decided that we needed to make business
case for investment of their own
leadership of their own time and
resources in this most critical problem
and so we needed to write the theory we
needed to write what's now become called
politics industry theory because by
demystifying it using this business lens
of competition thinking then we generate
an understanding that leads to
engagement so in 2016 I asked Michael to
join me to write about this because
we're using the five forces it was so
fabulous and we started writing and then
in 2017 we published at Harvard Business
School where Michael is a report as at
which you mentioned we got a great
reception it's really brought this idea
of healthy competition versus unhealthy
competition to the fore and people are
talking about it we always need more
people talking about it and that's why
now we've turned it into a book why
we're talking to you today and going
forward it's really all about driving
the action so we believe that we have
the right prescription how can you now
take that to scale across the country
and for me I sold my company that gives
me the freedom to do this
work and I'm all-in it's my passion
project and I can't think of something
that I'd rather be doing because if
politics is the preeminent barrier to
solving the issues that are facing us as
a country very interesting you know when
you run business originally you go in
thinking it's just about I want to grow
a company I want to make an impact I
want to do this and then the bigger you
get you realize how much of a role
politics plays within a company and you
never thought like you had to deal with
politics why I thought it's just
competition and then you notice there's
politics there so so I see the
similarity there but now you know the
one thing I do want to talk about before
I get into my question with you is you
talk about the five stages of political
grief you went through would you mind
sharing that with the audience oh sure
yeah that's interesting so some of the
audience may know there's a you know
five stages of grief the Elisabeth
kubler-ross when you grieve the loss of
someone or something important in your
life and so for me as I cared about
politics as a citizen and a business
leader because again as you're noting
the political environment the u.s.
competitiveness matter to business so
I'm deeply caring I've got my child I
care about her future and now I think
politics is screwed up so I said I must
get involved and I did what people often
do which is I chose a candidate so I had
known state Senator Barack Obama for
some number of years in Chicago and I
got deeply involved in his 2008 campaign
I was all in for hope and change and
then after his administration was in
office for a while I was paying close
attention and I served in a role in that
administration and I was disappointed by
what we were able to produce out of
Washington DC and I said wow if we can
send this extraordinary candidate to the
office and yet Washington DC is
functioning similarly to how it
functioned before gosh maybe
candidates are not the answer so that's
the first stage not candidates I said I
know I'll get involved in policy so then
I get deeply
Elden policy and I find out huh
what do you know behind the closed doors
there's reasonable agreement across both
sides about what are the policies to
solve our most pressing issues
there's just no political will so I go
okay not policy I know I'll get involved
in culture so I joined up with a
movement you know at high levels of a
movement that was trying to bring
everybody together and and and we got a
lot of pledges of bipartisanship in the
house in the Senate and yet when it came
time to vote
everybody voted the same way so they say
they want bipartisanship but they don't
vote that way so I say oh culture is not
enough and then I said I know I work on
candidates again but now I will try and
elect candidates that are independent so
they're not beholden to either side of
the duopoly and guess what they can't
get elected so that was the fourth stage
and finally as I noted before I read
Mickey Edwards book in 2013 the light
bulb went off it's a systems problem I
have never looked back and my grief is
all about the system now but that grief
also informs my hope which is it's not a
mystery the reasons for our dysfunction
are clear there in the rules and the
incentives of the system and so we have
the power to change them so now I'm done
with grief and I'm full into hope and
change yet again
well separately so a first stage
choosing a candidate then you realize
okay that's not the way to go number two
was policies number three was culture
number number four was a independent
candidate and a number five fifth stage
was changing the system systems
incentives rules systems incentives
rules I like the system so which which
stage you think is going to be media is
there going to be a stage number six
which is media or no no there isn't
going to be
because what's so interesting about any
sort of human endeavor is that systems
and culture and communication there are
all kinds of things that drive behavior
but what's really important and we learn
this in business is not to spend our
time the moaning the things over which
we have no control but rather to focus
intently and solely on the things where
we have leverage so as citizens we have
leverage it's not easy to get this
leverage but we have it on the system
there is no leverage available to you no
wave a magic wand and change the way
Media works in our country or the world
so I listen to sage advice from Michael
Porter who is famously known for saying
strategy is about choosing what not to
do and Michael and I keep our work
solely in this intersection of what we
call powerful and achievable we want to
do things that are powerful enough to
make a difference not just things that
feel good and then we want to do things
that we can actually achieve not just
tilt at windmills I'm very curious to
know as we go into this conversation to
roll a media plays because you know
there's an element of that where you
know like what I've noticed for myself
with the pandemic is if you went back 50
years ago I don't know if we would have
responded to it the same way we did
today and how much more of a role a
local politics plays like in LA you got
a mayor telling them certain things to
do that scaring the hell out of folks in
LA and Dallas is handling it in a
different way and as well as the raw
media place so it's interesting your
take but maybe we'll visit that here in
a minute so a michael question for you
again going back to the question about
competition and business competition and
politics the difference between those
two why should the average person that's
watching this who is kind of sitting
there saying I see
I really don't know about the policies I
keep hearing about this gerrymandering
thing I don't even know what
gerrymandering is I think I watched a
video one town where they take the
people and they split it so you know the
governor back in the days I think he was
from Massachusetts that he kind of
changed this and his last name was Jerry
and he changed it to be able to beat
this other federalist guy the social I
don't really know what's really going on
there and why should I care Michael from
your point of view a business point of
view why should the average person
watching this care to want to change
politics because most of the people I
talk to they're just kind of thrown in
the towel saying I don't trust
politicians and I really don't want to
do nothing about it
what would you say to them well it's
funny you know the the journey on my
side really reflected that point
absolutely directly now we at Harvard
Business School and I work a lot on
competitiveness and economic development
and why countries prosper and work with
many countries around the world it's
really about moving our Spidy forward
and making our collectivist environment
better and we noticed about a decade ago
that the performance of the American
economy was really really really bad we
were seeing results slow growth slow
productivity our our skills were
declining relative to other countries
our education system was declining
relative to other countries and at the
school we sort of came together and say
it's our responsibility at Harvard
Business School we understand what's
going on here you know why are we not
making headway why is our our economy
getting more competitive why are
American businesses not thriving the way
they should
around the world and so we we started
this big project collected a lot of data
and and we came up with an assessment of
the US business environment with a
two-by-two matrix you know like we
always have here at Harvard and what's
but most of it was things that were not
good and things were getting worse we
out of that analysis we came up with
what we call the eight point plan we
came up with the eight things that
America has to do if it's going to
ultimately restore the energy and the
dynamism
of the American economy and it was it
was all fairly basic things it was like
we gotta fix the tax code so that we're
not bankrupting ourselves with deficits
and we've got the right incentives so
that companies can invest we gotta have
a decent policy to allow rational and
immigration of highly skilled
individuals into America that had been a
real strength we had tremendous
immigration but we've had this battle
over immigration for so many years and
it's a divisive issue and it turns
Americans against Americans then we
talked about with international trading
system that we live in have some
disadvantages for America there were
some things that were distortions and
and and kind of getting in the way of a
really fair competition so we had to do
something about that we we have crummy
infrastructure you know in America we
everybody knows this it's just a
catastrophe how bad our infrastructure
is on all the metrics and my favorite
example is if you land at Kennedy
Airport and this is no disrespect to New
York it's you land at Kennedy Airport
and you look down at that Airport you
took off in China or Switzerland or
almost anywhere else in the world you
land at Kennedy Airport it's a joke it's
an embarrassment it doesn't work and and
that that cuts across a lot of our
infrastructure our railroad system and
so forth we deal with a sustainable
budget I mean our budget which is out of
control and nobody sort of thinks that
we'll ever have to pay it back but we
can't reform entitlements we couldn't do
anything to kind of get our house in
order and so what we did was we took
this eight-point plan and I'll never
forget this this is my really first six
books on large scale and we trip down to
Washington and we started meeting with
members of Congress and I went with Jan
Rifkin who's my colleague that was
co-chair of this this project and by the
way what year was this if you don't mind
me asking this was about 2012 or 13 okay
and we went down and it was funny every
member of Congress and Senator that we
asked for an appointment they gave it to
us
I mean we got in we got through the door
I think that's because they respect
Harvard Business School and think it's a
fine institution so we went in there and
we explained the analysis of what we
what was going wrong in the economy and
why we weren't progressing and why
income inequality was rising why
economic growth was slow we went in
there and everybody not in their head
you know through the whole conversation
and yeah that sounds right to me that
that's what we think that too is I said
and then I said talk about the
eight-point plan here's what we need to
do and as we were describing what we
need to do everybody was nodding their
head yeah we need to deal with our
infrastructure yeah we need to improve
our tax incentives in our tax code yeah
you we need to improve our training in
education system in America everybody
nodded their head we have to have an
immigration policy but then what we
discovered and sometimes they actually
told us before we left they said look we
agree with all these things and we think
they're great ideas but it's gonna be
really really hard to get anything done
and that created this incredible puzzle
that how can we not do rational things
that will make our country thrive when
the people involved understand that
that's what they should do and and
that's when for me that you know had
already started you know brainwashing me
about you know politics because she knew
something about it I didn't know
anything I was just doing my work and it
was really bad experience that showed
how important it is for us to have
people understand we need Americans to
understand this most Americans have no
idea why this happens they just think
it's normal it's natural it's the way
it's always been we can't agree we
always have fights on stuff and and and
we just we just came to the view that
and we had a responsibility as the
Harvard Business School to do something
about that so with very fortunately I
knew Katherine certain she asked me to
join this work and we we developed a way
of understanding it and since then this
has been really one of my passions
because we can't deal with this issue
our country is in serious trouble and by
the way I haven't mentioned it's not
just economic policy there were screwing
up it's also on our social agenda we
have we have discrimination against
minorities and violence that's that's
that's very high and and and we rank
very low versus other countries we we
ranked very low on all the education you
know we have we are maternal mortality
in America maternal mortality United
States of America of all the countries
in the world
we're number sixty seconds and among the
OECD countries which is 36 countries
we're number 35 how could the United
States of America maternal mortality
like that child mortality like that
homicide rates off the chart
discrimination against minorities
inequality of political power even on
things like freedom of religion these
were these were bedrock principles when
we when this country was was put
together and somehow we've managed to
lose a lot of us we were the leader in
social progress we were the leader in
creating opportunity for people now it's
just about eradicating the American
dream because it's it's very hard for
most people to you know do better than
their parents anymore and so it this is
a I think people don't understand
politics is not just sideshow it's
really at the core of what's going on in
the United States of America and it's
gonna determine had a huge impact on our
future and as Katherine said it's you
know we tried different kinds of
presidents from both parties and we've
tried you know all kinds of different
things isn't working and that's because
we hadn't really understood how really
actually functions as a system so so
this is this is something that has
become an obsession for me I'm obsessed
with this as I successful this country
by the way I love that you're obsessed
with it because macaws of word you're at
and you're positioning it gives me a lot
of hope knowing to God
he was obsessed with the bottle is this
the article The Economist that you guys
wrote and no yes okay for anybody that's
watching this if you want to read the
article we're gonna put it below on the
8 points going back to it you know I'm
sure many companies have come up to you
and they've said look we're kind of
experiencing gridlock AIG is one of the
carriers we write the most I run an
insurance company with 15,000 agents and
AIG is a good-sized company one other
they used to be one of the
too-big-to-fail companies yeah
and if these companies who are behemoths
these are a hundred billion auto
companies two hundred billion dollar
companies three hundred million dollar
companies and when you go ask to give
change request for change there's a
couple things I learned one the best
advice I got was 15 years ago by another
man his name was Jack I used to call and
ask for a lot of requests and he says
look pick 50 issues out of the 50 issues
which one's your number one only ask for
one thing per year because if you ask
for too many things they're not gonna do
it for you so if you're if you're able
to put a weight behind one thing what
would it be
and that's a corporation we're talking
about if US was a corporation it's a
three and a half trillion dollar you're
you know the numbers you know the amount
of employees 160 million employees that
are currently working a fourth that's
right now not working unemployed two to
coronavirus etc etc if you were to say
for someone like you and someone who
came and became your consultant and they
said Michael I suggest when you go to
these guys at the top these politicians
you know you go to them with eight
issues they're not gonna pay attention
to any of it but you can only choose one
of them to bring to them what is the one
thing above all that you would say we
need to start off with out of these
eight well we've got to change the
incentives and the rules that are
guiding what those political leaders are
in what they're stuck in right now and
we will tone we'll talk about this later
I mean if we have primary elections the
way we have today we're gonna have a
hard time ever getting there because
it's impossible to win a primary
election unless you appeal to the
partisans on your side and if you
whoo bipartisan you may very well get it
knocked down in the next primary or your
party might run somebody against you
that is more right than you are
so the problem actually it's not there's
a rationing of what policy is the most
important they're all important it's
it's the system has to change if people
are going to have even a possibility of
solving any problem now it's it's the
system beautifully in trig intricately
designed to sort of freeze the status
quo and we just can't get anything done
and the parties would rather not do
something as long as then compromise and
go against their base and go against
their their partisan so I think I think
what I came to understand again
Katherine this is way ahead of me here
in understanding and they're saying the
reality but over over these these months
and years as we've been working on this
I think we're starting to understand
it's the people serving us in Washington
are stuck they are kind of trapped and
no matter how well-meaning they are and
no matter whether they care they're
stuck in a system where they they are
neutralized from really making real
progress you know we've had we had
25,000 discussions of the infrastructure
in Washington everybody knows we got to
build infrastructure right now with Cova
and all the unemployment Wow what if we
had a big infrastructure program we can
have hundreds of thousands of job good
jobs out there we've been fixing our
roads and all that kind of stuff but we
had every time we got a good
infrastructure bill the same thing
happens can't agree can't agree can't
agree you can't get it done can't pass
so it's it's a perverse system and I
think most Americans I found in most
business people don't understand it they
just don't get it what is this this goes
against everything we're taught in
business we got to be rational we have
any thoughtful we got to do the right
thing we got to move the ball forward
it's not like this it's it's a it's a
difference and Katherine knows more
about it than probably anybody else so
so fair enough so what you said is your
number one would
the system incentive rule which was kind
of a Katherine's fifth stage of grief so
you're putting that as a number one
thing that we need to watch we can build
on it okay so before I go to Katherine
and kind of have her share with us her
ideas and some of the suggestions that
she has let's talk about the industry of
politics how big is the industry of
politics well it's pretty big industry
it's very hard to get numbers because
there's a lot of strange rules about
disclosure where you can do things
without having to disclose it that's the
part of a part of the way the parties
kind of retain control as they of what
having to disclose too much but our best
estimate a couple of years ago was it's
about you know 16 to 20 billion dollar
industry it employs probably tens of
thousands of people and it's not just
the people working in the legislature in
Washington and so forth it's it's what
we've come to call the political
industrial complex there's a whole bunch
of actors that live off politics the
lobbying industry lives off politics
hundreds pounders of very well-paid
lobbyists that are living off of
politics there's all the people that run
campaigns and do polling and campaign
managers and all that sort of that's a
big industry there's there's a
substantial there's a bunch of think
tanks now they're in the politics
industry their job is to you know come
up with the ideas and try to you know
get their legislation passed the things
that they think are the important things
to do and and you can already see just
thinking about think tanks think tanks
you know what think tanks used to be
needs to be neutral and more scholarly I
like that anymore they become sucked in
to the partisanship so the think tanks
are either you know more over the left
or more with the right and their job is
a think tank is to get the left stuff
done or the right stuff done depending
on you know who outside they're on and
there
their donors what that so we can tell
story after story after story but but
the problem is that this giant industry
is all interconnected and again it's
it's all designed around the left and
the right the Republicans and the
Democrats and by the way we haven't said
this yet but we must say it Patrick we
are not against Republicans and we're
not against Democrats we we don't think
that these are bad people but we think
what's happened is that it's this
competition that's been created it's
this way of competing it's this way that
they've structure the industry that his
is perverting our democracy and we've
got to change that and I think a lot of
people in Washington would really like
to be able to pass legislation that we
really need they think so I think so I
think a lot of people are frustrated by
it
we know that partly from history and I
don't want to get too far afield but
back in about 1890 in the United States
of America we had the same kind of mess
that we have today and it's tremendously
partisan gridlock
you know irrational political system and
it was a period of American history
called the Gilded Age the country was
still you know relatively young country
and it was a mess but in those days you
when you went to the voting bloc you
picked up a ballot and the ballot you
can tell by the ballot that you picked
up whether it was a Republican ballot or
a democratic vote and so I had it was
these poor citizens who ignore the
polling place they pick up their
whatever about and then as they're
walking into in a vote all these people
there would be you know hitting on them
and trying to convince them to change
their mallet and oh you know I can get
used I can get you into this whatever if
you do this if you change your mallet
I'll do something so we have a lot of
corruption
the party's on the newspapers there was
a Republican newspaper and a Democratic
newspaper in a city and the Republican
newspaper talking about only about
Republican stuff and the Democratic only
government so today we have some
polarization media too and the media is
sort of aligned with one side or the
other in many cases so so we had this
back and you know in in nineteen
nineteen hundred and it was so bad that
we couldn't get anything done we had
gridlock we had frustrated people our
country was struggling and at that
moment in history citizens thank
goodness
decided this is unacceptable we have to
change this and so we had something in
America called the Progressive Era you
may have heard that phrase and literally
our whole political system was changed
the rules were changed for example it
used to be that the state legislature
would determine who the US senator would
be from each state you didn't get to
vote for the Senate the legislators in
the system decided to the senator was
going to be there was all kinds of stuff
like that
and one by one these rules were changed
and the rationale the rationalization
came back into our politics so we
believe that today or restart that
movement and and we really need to
understand that Americans are gonna have
to take control let the parties do it if
we let the politics doesn't do it not
gonna change it's stuck
but if Americans can understand what's
really going on they can understand
these kind of things that we're talking
about we think there's a lot of people
that are incredibly frustrated with the
system that are incredibly frustrated
with what isn't happening in America
that are not you know they don't stand
for inequality they don't want that you
know yeah and yet we haven't known what
to do we've known that you can give
money to a candidate but give you money
doesn't matter the candidates gonna have
to run through an election processes
turn them into whatever that that turns
them into so we've got the moment we've
got to seize an opportunity to move this
system in a very different direction and
it's taken a long time
a lot of help and insight and a lot of
leadership by Katherine to make this
work and I think we're getting there
and we can talk later if you want about
what's happening in different parts of
the country because there's promising
things happening and we're moving now
we're actually starting to move whether
we can get it over the goal line I think
is going to depend on how many citizens
can actually understand this how many
people will make the investment to kind
of get this because I think most
Americans are very dissatisfied I have a
lot of follow-up questions for you but
I'm gonna go to Katherine first and then
I'll come back to you so Katherine
currently today I mean part of what we
were talking about last night currently
today we have a duopoly we have really
two parties right you have the
Republicans and you have the Democrats
and god forbid somebody on a third party
decides to go in whether a Ross Perot
who got 18.9% in 92 I think he also went
in 96 as well it was dole himself and
Clinton that they went I don't think I
think he only got like 8% in 96 but in
92 he got 18.9% created some momentum
we've seen the Johnson Garry John we've
seen the Ron Paul's of the world create
some momentum Howard Schultz went and
then boom hey you're gonna hurt the
Democratic Party if you go in and here's
a guy that runs 400,000 employees he
wants to go in there are a lot of people
behind closed doors that sit there and
say look you don't sound like a Democrat
and the other person says you don't
sound like a Republican then what the
hell are we maybe there is something
else out there that we are because we
have a lot of things we agree with are
we ready for a third party so so what is
your suggestion to those of us that
don't 100% relate with the Republican
Party and no one hundred percent relate
to the Democratic Party is it time for
us to go to a third party and have yes
how the hell do we do it okay I love
this stuff because the situation is so
bad but the answers are there for us so
let's step back for just a moment and
remind ourselves something I said
earlier that in politics we do not have
we don't get results and there's no
accountability for not getting results
so that means that we have fundamentally
unhealthy competition in the politics
industry so we're the customers the
citizens are the customers the public
interest is supposed to be the customer
and that's what the politic system
should deliver but instead the customer
is not getting at all what they need for
what now in any other industry that it
that's this large and and thriving and
so Michael talked about the size of the
political industrial complex at 16 to 20
billion dollars if you're in an industry
that big and that profitable and the
customer is you know hated the industry
essentially which is we have very low
approval rating of Congress then you
would so much preneur probably you
Patrick
would see this as a phenomenal business
opportunity and you would come in with a
new competitor to give the customer what
the customer wants but that doesn't
happen in politics right we're all
dissatisfied and there's no new
competition so that's because a system
had has actually been constructed in a
way where the parties the two sides have
worked together in one particular way
super well behind the scenes which is to
construct a system that protects
themselves jointly from new competition
and fundamentally can you say that one
more time it's very you said it very
subtly can you say that one more time
very powerful what you just said right
there yes so we think Republicans and
Democrats don't work together behind the
scenes they work very well together in
one particular way and that is to rig
the rules of the game to protect
themselves jointly from any new
competition right and without
competition we will never have results
or accountability competition is what
delivers results to customers in every
industry so let's let's look at this so
what I can do it's very interesting
because
essentially we don't get results and
there's no accountability and when we
get into this I'll be able to show
what's the primary reason we don't get
results and what's the primary reason
there's no accountability for not
getting results so let's start because
you asked me about this accountability
question so think about it this way we
have this duopoly and there's no new
competition there's no accountability
because the customer only has these two
choices so the only thing that either
side needs to do to win is to convince
the average voter to choose them as the
lesser of two evils or because at least
they say therefore what that herder
believes but what the parties don't have
to do in a duopoly is deliver results
because no matter how disappointed you
are you still likely prefer what your
side says therefore than what the one
other choice says therefore so instead
of results in the public interest you
get this gridlock and dysfunctional
drama the lack of new competition comes
in large part from one thing that we as
a country chose by accident so back when
the founders no created this
extraordinary country you know a system
of democracy and our Constitution there
weren't great examples of democracies to
look to for how we should run things day
to day and so they said oh yeah let's
vote this way let's have something
called plurality voting because Britain
uses this for some of their elections
and what plurality voting is is that
whoever has the most votes wins let's
sound super rational but it turns out to
have a little bit of a problem well a
big problem so right now in any election
of more than two candidates someone can
win without having true majority they
don't have to have over 50% for example
in a three-way race a candidate could
win with 34 percent of the votes and the
66 percent would split between the other
two
and plurality voting is the single
greatest barrier to
competition in our entire system because
it creates this spoiler effect so what
this Euler effect is that sometimes we
don't vote for the candidate we really
want to vote for out of fear that will
inadvertently contribute to the election
of the candidate we like the least if
you think back to 2016 there you know we
think of Clinton and Trump but there
were also two other candidates that had
reasonable you know name recognition in
the race one was from the left Jill
Stein and one was from the right here at
Johnson and people who liked Jill Stein
on the Left were essentially set told it
can't vote for her because if you do you
will steal votes away from Hillary
Clinton who would have been your second
choice and you'll spoil the election for
her and inadvertently help elect Donald
Trump and for people on the right if you
wanted to vote for Gary Johnson a
libertarian who were essentially told
our system tells you oh you can't vote
for Gary Johnson because it'll take that
vote away from Trump you know it you'll
spoil the election for him and you
inadvertently helped elect Hillary now
the spoiler problem we see that there I
give that as an example but the real
effective is for the problem is that
most no competition never enters the
race in the first place because they
know they're going to be considered just
a spoiler so you mentioned Patrick
Howard Schultz so some of your viewers
may remember that in the spring of 2019
he considered getting in the
presidential race as an independent but
people felt that he was much closer to
the Democrat to Democrats shall we say
and so the Democratic Party was livid
because they believe that a Schultz
candidacy would never win but they
believed that he would take enough votes
away from the eventual Democratic
nominee to throw the election to Donald
Trump and the response was really quite
vicious and you know Howard Schultz
didn't end up pursuing that race
I promise you the Republicans would be
equally outraged if someone of that kind
of profile and success wanted to run as
a Republican because they say oh he'll
ruin the election for Trump so that's
why we don't get this new competition
now I want to also know you you
mentioned Perot
so Perot actually did win it did run he
didn't win he got you know close to 19%
and he wasn't a spoiler people think he
was but he wasn't some new analysis
statistical analysis has proven that but
what Perot did was put healthy
competition and system and you might
remember he ran very much in these
current about the debt and the deficit
our fiscal situations that were spending
too much and guess what Rodan win but
the Republicans and the Democrats in the
Clinton administration cooperated to
deliver budget surpluses they got a
balanced budget they actually got a
surplus we've never had one since and we
give credit to that to Clinton and to a
lesser degree than to Newt Gingrich and
the Republicans here is the credit card
the credit goes to competition because
both parties were afraid that grows
nascent you know new party was going to
do better and better and threaten them
and they didn't want that to happen so
they said we better solve this issue so
that people don't vote for him the next
time
that's what competition does you won't
have to win in healthy competition to
benefit the customer so we have to do is
change the way we vote to get rid of the
spoiler problem so that we can put the
forces of competition in not because
it's Michael said we're not against
Republicans we're not against Democrats
we're against what you know they're
producing or relatively not producing
right now but we're not saying it would
be better if one wins or the other wins
or a third party wins what we're saying
is we need the forces of competition of
candidates and
Jia's to create results so it's not
about changing who wins it's about
changing what whoever wins does the
question is are they gonna let you do
this no I mean you're going up against
some by the way Newt Gingrich I think
was the man of the year 1995 Time
magazine which was pretty insane to see
those guys make it work it was almost
like him and Tip O'Neill that you're
Reagan and Tip O'Neill was a very
interesting dynamic competition the
question is do you really think you said
the Democratic Party is how vicious they
were towards Schultz I can't believe
what you're doing and I remember in the
documentary where President Bush senior
at the end of the documentary the
interviewer asks him what are your
thoughts about Ross Perot it was the
only topic he didn't want to talk about
because I don't want to talk about Ross
Perot I don't want to talk about Rosco
because in his mind if it wasn't Ross
Perot he would have gotten reelected
obviously you said a different study
that it wouldn't made a difference
anyways because he's still won by seven
percent so it doesn't make a difference
but if they're gonna be so vicious on
both sides Republican or Democrat if
they're gonna be so vicious who's on
your side to even want to support you
for this to become a reality you need
some powerful people to be on your side
to help you make this happen who are
those people well believe it or not the
most powerful people are the collective
of the American citizens the voters so
not in every case
now here's what I mean this is so
interesting you know what I said earlier
that we only do things we only work on
things Michael and I they're powerful
but also things that are achievable now
that doesn't mean that the things that
we say are achievable are easy to get
done but they're possible so for example
some reformers think we need to change
the system in a way that requires
constitutional amendments well nothing
we're proposing requires a
constitutional amendment because that
would be a waste of everybody's time for
me to tell you that what it's gonna take
to change the system is a constitutional
amendment which we're never gonna get I
mean it wouldn't be worth your time or
your viewers time to be listening to us
so what we're talking about are two
changes to how we vote that we can get
here's how we get that very interesting
these
important rules like the one that
creates floor ality voting and the one
that creates the party primary problem
we're not in the Constitution the
Constitution is super short and it turns
out that most of the rules that govern
day-to-day behavior and incentives are
just ones that you know have been kind
of made up over time and the
Constitution delegates virtually all of
the rules about how we vote to the
states so the states get to make those
decisions that's why sometimes when
we're watching the presidential primary
we're like how come it's different in
Washington State then it is an Illinois
or Wisconsin or something well because
it states made different rules but that
means that we can change these rules
state by state and in twenty six states
the states long ago gave the people the
opportunity to put issues on the ballot
if they wanted to bypass the legislature
which in this case would be sort of
bypassing the political industrial
complex
so in 26 states we can put the proposal
that that would need to talk about
called final five voting
actually on the ballot citizens can vote
for it and if 51% vote for it it's done
or 50% plus one vote it's done and
that's half the state and let me tell
you that pressure will make a huge
difference in the other states because
people in the other states will say hey
we want that system to additionally like
Michael said politicians want to make a
difference they do can we find stories
where we think that structure sure but
really people want to make a difference
people love this country this system
will be so much better to work in that
in the states that don't have ballot
referendums I believe a combination of
the the business leadership that job
creators in those states with the
citizens saying we need you state
legislators have changed these rules for
Congress so that our country can
function again along with you know
Congress's individual politicians
desires to work in a functional system
and be able to pass those
policies that Michael was talking about
earlier they will eventually see this is
actually better for them there's such a
small number of losers the leaders of
the political industrial complex the
ones who have made out in the system and
there's a huge number of winners so
again in summary we're gonna put it to a
vote
in 26 states and or the legislature is
going to pass it in any state in the
country and that we can get done and I
hope we'll get to specifically the
package of what needs to be passed yeah
so so what I think about when you're
saying is I'm sitting there said okay
how big and maybe you have an answer to
this how big is the percentage of people
that would agree for a need of a third
party is it a five percent number a ten
percent number a fifteen percent number
because you've heard the number when
Romney said 47 percent all that video
came out it got viral it says well you
know the 47 percent and you know the 45
47 let's just say it's 45 45 on each
side's Democrats are going to be
Democrats Republicans are going to be
the Republicans what is that number of
people that are independent libertarians
or third parties who we know that number
yeah so I want to answer that question
and then tell you why it's less
important than we think so interestingly
in the country all we hear about in the
media is the Democrats think this and
the Republicans think this and you would
think that means that half the people
think this and half think the other
thing that turns out only 27 percent of
the country less than a third identify
as Democrat and only 26 percent so
essentially the same number less than a
third on both sides actually identify as
Democrats and Republicans so what does
everybody else identify as well they
self-identify as independents now that
doesn't mean they're a monolithic bloc
of people in the middle this could
include people who are libertarian or
people who are a Green Party or people
who have a whole different set of ideas
but 46% of people close to half the
country says that they're not either one
of the two choices we have so that means
that it's not just a question of a third
party it's a question of
new ideas new policies I mean the
duopoly has so controlled our thoughts
that we sort of think oh well we only
have two so maybe three would be better
it's not to three or seven the question
is is there an opportunity for a new
competitor to threaten whoever the
players are if they don't get things
done so it's fine if we have to if
they're delivering but they're not
delivering so we have to have the threat
of a new competitor that's essentially
going to take their market share and
then they may just decide to improve
their product to themselves or indeed
the new competitors will come in so
there's not a magic number of parties
the point is to have the system open to
new competitors new ideas new candidates
who are anywhere along the spectrum
along the spectrum and then that
improves the results the difference we I
always talk about political innovation I
don't talk about political reform
because a lot of times there are
multiple reasons for that but one is
that political reform can tend to deal
with things about fairness and equality
and moral issues of democracy which is
super-important or political reform can
deal with can be sort of a Trojan horse
for party advantage when we talk about
political innovation it's solely focused
on results meaning results that the
system gives to the American people so
we're not trying to change things
because it would feel better we're
trying to change only things that would
affect Congress's ability to solve
problems to actually fix things and
that's what political innovation is so
no boy I've talked so long I'm
practically from getting your question
let me ask you let me go back to that
because you said the you know the 4545
you said they did a study and they
notice that they're the true Democrat is
only 27% of Americans
the Republicans about 26% and the rest
is pretty much everybody else that's
kind of in the middle who did that study
in that research because that's that's
very interesting to me you know I
actually don't have the attribution
right in front of me but I'm gonna send
that to you after this and everybody
that's watching it we're gonna put it
below for you to look through it because
that's a very interesting for a for me
to look I totally want to see that
intuition Oh we'll put it up so
everybody else in the audience can see a
matter of fact a lot of your powerpoints
gonna be into presentation so in post
edit when we go through that but but
let's stay on that so the question I was
asking was the following is so if we're
gonna have a third party someone is
going to take a hit for a couple
elections I mean it's naive to think
it's not gonna be that way and here's
what I mean by I'm gonna play devil's
advocate and you can push back all you
want because I I I support the fact that
I'd love to have a third party you know
you go to India I've been in India and
they'll say we got 45 plus political
parties but it's really only three or
four political parties you'll go to
Mexico and oh so we got five different
political parties but it's really only
three political parties the
conservatives or socialists and the
Democrats and that's kind of what they
have going on over there you can go to a
lot of different places but someone is
gonna have to take a hit one of the
sides to agree on having a third party
and why would a party want to do that so
it's almost like Democrats gonna say
okay you guys go through it first not us
or Republicans are gonna say no no you
guys deal with your Howard Schultz first
or your Mark Cuban first let him cause
an independent but it's really a
Democrat
oh no no no why don't you guys
experience your own Republican and yeah
a John Kasich let him go I say them
independent what is really a Republican
which party is gonna be willing to give
up first I that's the challenge I see
it's so vicious it's so ugly it's so
dirty who's gonna want to give up one
election especially since all this money
and jobs are on the line neither neither
one is gonna want to give it up but they
don't have to let me tell you how this
works so I want to just say what the
answer and it's not the only answer it's
just the most important answer it's deep
without changing this none of the other
answers will have enough
how hard it changed how Washington works
we need something called final five bode
that's what our book is all about so
people can learn the details in the book
Minh in summary final five voting
changes to things in our election system
one is we get rid of party primaries
because party primaries create an eye of
the needle to which no problem
politician from either side can pass
meaning they're pushed to the right and
left Michael talked about that earlier
they can't come together to solve
anything because they'll lose their
primary so there you go we're just done
you can't get anything done because
there's no connection between doing the
right things for the public for the
public interest and getting reelected
and we have a great rap on that there's
no connection between those things
that's absolutely crazy if you want to
get things done so we get rid of the
party primary and then this end we have
instead a nonpartisan primary where
everybody is on the same ballot and the
top five vote getters will go forward to
the general election
then in a general election we're going
to get rid of that plurality voting
system that we sort of chose by accident
when the country started it's just what
that seems fine but now we know that
that system is what keeps out new
competition third parties fourth fifth
sixth seventh any or Independence
anything a new competition so we replace
plurality voting with ranked choice
voting and again we can learn all about
this in our book or on our website I
won't give all the details now all
they're happy to if you want me to and
in this case when you use ranked choice
voting it eliminates the spoiler problem
it means that no new competition
automatically takes away the ability of
let's say the current duopoly to win but
it does inject the new ideas and the
competition in and now there's no reason
to force a Mark Cuban out of the race to
force in Michael Bloomberg not to run to
they don't vote for Jill Stein or don't
vote for Gary Johnson with rank-choice
voting that is not a problem because in
the end rank-choice voting means you
have to win with the majority you have
to have over 50% so let me ask a
question right there let me not Scotia
I'm right because I went through what I
was reading in Chapter five I was going
through it and I watch the video as well
is do I have to rank everybody like can
I leave anything empty or I'd have to
vote rank Oh No so in wrenchers voting
and and maybe we'll be able to put the
way the ballot look in Rachel's voting
you can rank as many or as few as you
want so if you want to just have one
choice the way you're already stood this
is my favorite and want to cast your
ballot for that person absolutely no
problem you don't need to know about all
the candidates if you don't want to if
you have an opinion on two of them you
can write them you can also you know you
might know who's your favorite and who's
your least favorite and not care as much
about the people in between so you can
do all of those things and again what's
so interesting is rent choice voting in
our theory is less about changing who
wins and more about providing the
opportunity in final high voting for
five candidates five sets of ideas to be
heard so you could have a Perot running
on debt and deficit and bringing that
issue to the fore on a regular basis and
even if she or he doesn't win whoever
does win will have seen what the voters
had to say about that particular issue
so I want to come back now an answer you
know how we're gonna get this done
because you're saying well one party's
gonna have to give first and what I'm
saying is first they don't have to give
because they'll be in the hunt and
rank-choice voting just like everybody
else and they if they deliver what the
public wants they will absolutely still
win they'll still win but if they don't
then some entrepreneurial politician
will
have an opportunity that is not
available now and we will pass this
state-by-state and so the the parties
won't have a say the citizens will do it
or the legislators will do it and then
and then the system will be implemented
and what's also really amazing about
this I just love this is that we don't
have to get this done in 50 states
before we see the benefits as a country
think about this Patrick if we pass
final five voting which means
nonpartisan top five primaries plus
rank-choice voting general election it's
a package final five voting if we pass
final five voting in five states we
would have immediately ten senators and
we could have you know anywhere
depending on the states you know maybe
let's call it 50 representatives that
would be in Washington DC
responding to a different set of
incentives now they may be very well
maybe Republicans Democrats still but
they got elected by a majority in their
district they don't have to go through
the eye of the needle that is a party
primaries so they can't be pushed
further to the left to the right they
can sign bipartisan compromise
legislation if they want to and still
make it through their primary that's
totally critical and they serve as a
fulcrum in a sense which can serve as a
bridge between the between the parties
and the people responding to the
traditional incentives because if you
had 10 senators who could be the yes
votes on the infrastructure bill or
could be the yes folks on a on a you
sort of debt deficit reduction where we
work on revenues and spending and they
know they can still get reelected even
if they're Republicans or Democrats we
can really change in the existing system
leave the other 45 states the same we
can change how this works
so I am blown away all the time by the
fact that when we
you looked at the system and decided
what was the most important thing to
change it turned out that the most
important thing to change is also
something that we can change and it also
turns out that we don't have to change
it every where to begin to get results
it's an unbelievable opportunity for the
country to pass final 5ot do we need
politicians to pass this do we need that
do we need any politicians for this to
pass so we need whatever it's gonna take
to convince the voters to say yes to it
in you know those twenty six days or
five of the twenty six states or we need
the legislators to say yes to it and but
we don't need one particular politicians
we just need leadership and this
leadership is out there in spades in
former elected officials okay so some
names like if you were to say here are
five names that would get behind someone
like this to help it pass who would they
be
that's so interesting so I do have a
list of names which shall remain
nameless here for the people that I
think would be the greatest leaders of
this movement like the greatest
spokespeople and they are people from
the left and people from the right are
they currently in office are they
currently you know people who used to be
in office are the ones that can say it
shouldn't be this way people that used
to be in office are the ones that can
say that it shouldn't be this way yeah
they can tell the truth look
hypothetically would a guy like Newt be
on that list oh I'd love to talk to Newt
Gingrich I still carry around a business
card that Newt Gingrich gave me years
ago when I sat next to him at a dinner
it's sort of a long story but I have
business card and wrote something very
funny on the back of it and I still have
it in my wallet so yes I really this is
a pleat Newt Gingrich I'd like to talk
to you about this Newt this is what we
need to do the new sort of what was that
a contract with America that he had
right and this is should be our new
contract with the American people final
five voting so that Washington DC
politicians can have great careers and
deliver results I mean that's what we
need I want you
put this up one of our slides the
current system there's no connection
between getting results and getting
elected it would be like there's no
connection between doing your job well
and keeping your job nobody would run a
company that way but that's how we run
our political system and then in the new
system after final 5 OD oh you're going
to illustrate for me after final 5 OD we
create a connection between delivering
results and keeping your job yes and all
this this sounds this sounds good but
this is this is where I'm at with my but
it's a big but ok yeah no if this is a
pipeline we're going through and we want
to get final 5 voting you have to go
through somebody's who are these people
that we need to go through to get this
because the idea sounds good but what
who do you need to go through to get
that it's not we can't just say here's
what we're gonna do to change the voting
some of the people we have to go through
aren't they existing politicians and
decision makers you don't in the 26
states that have a referendum how you
get to vote on the issue meaning there
would be here let me step back for a
moment so in 26 states the citizens can
vote on an issue on the on the when they
go in to vote for the president so let's
say they would go in in November and
they're going to choose who they're
voting for for president and at the same
time there will be a line that says
essentially you vote YES for final 5
voting or you vote no for final 5 OD and
then if it's 50% plus one voting yes
final 5 voting is set in that state the
way that that final 5 voting question
gets on that ballot is that citizens
collect signatures the process is a
little different in each state but they
collect signatures and essentially then
it's on the ballot so they do not need
the permission of any members of the
political industrial complex to get this
on the ballot
is it takes the question out of the
hands of the political industrial
complex and gives it to the citizens
product so that's for half the states
and then in the other there's actually
great opportunities in legislative
states as well and I want to I want to
come back quickly and say I want to
highlight two particular existing
politicians you guys said its former
politicians who can tell the truth I
want to highlight two existing you know
people serving right now in Congress who
are already telling the truth they're
particularly courageous and that is
Republican Congressman Mike Gallagher
from Wisconsin and Democratic
congressman Chrissy Houlihan and they
wrote the foreword for a book I believe
you saw that yep these two congress
people who were elected Christie in 2018
Mike in 2016 we're both served in the
Armed Forces before this and when they
what they say in the foreword and I
encourage everybody to read the book to
see this it's very eloquent they say hey
when we were veterans when we were
serving the Armed Forces we were on the
same team working for the good of
America and then out of that same desire
of public service and serving America
that caused us to join the military we
ran for office and now we're in
Washington DC and for some reason were
automatically on different teams why
aren't we still on before America team
even though we have different ideologies
trying to find something that works and
they say it shouldn't have to be this
way and they endorse in this forward the
ideas that we have in the book so
specifically you know final five voting
and they're courageously saying that it
doesn't work and it could work and
should work and and we should make that
difference and there will be more and
more people like them and we have
already in Wisconsin again two
courageous legislators state senator
Dale kooyenga are
publican state representative Danny
reamer a Democrat again they both serve
in the military now in the in the
National Guard or the reserves I'm sorry
that I'm forgetting and they came
together in Wisconsin to say we need to
pass final five voting for our
congressional elections so there are
examples out there of existing people
serving now who are courageous to say
what's so and certainly the former's
they're ready to say what so okay so
here's a follow up for you now I'm gonna
go to Michael I got a follow up for you
here and I'll go to Michael so you know
how when you were valuing the company
when you gone through this before 2015
so the number that buyers want to see is
what even up right a better a better a
better what's the e better and then they
go through the formula okay so then you
have to go through your audited
financials then you have to go through
quality of earnings you remember when
you had to go through quality of
earnings and they want to see Deloitte
which by the way I think a company that
Michael you were on a board of a
consultant company I think was purchased
by Deloitte something like that you were
to use you part of yeah so like right
now we're going through Deloitte or PwC
and KPMG that's kind of the negotiation
what happens so you know what phase I'm
at and if you go through this the tax
implications of ASC 606 which is gonna
help you with the even on etc you know
what I'm talking about like these okay
awesome you know but but the point I'm
trying to make to you is this so you do
the math in one way a bit of favors you
you do the math in a different way even
it doesn't favor you if you do appraisal
in one way the appraisal of this house
is going to be two hundred eighty eight
thousand dollars less than if you do the
appraisal this way right okay so let's
just see if we go the route that you're
talking about okay let's just say we go
through the top five and and in the
philosophy that you have st. we go this
rod great there's a part where you talk
about Paul LePage right a tea party
Republican that ran and he won and you
know 37.6% and becomes the governor and
he's maybe not the most liked governor
that they ever
happen he got reelected and if it wasn't
if it was for this he wouldn't have
gotten reelected let's just say right so
if we were to change the voting system
that we have to what you're suggesting
who takes a hit can you be specific with
names because these models will show who
is gonna take a hit in what areas that
doesn't make a difference and in what
areas you know who's gonna you know take
advantage of because if this model
benefits Republicans well Democrats are
gonna say I'm not in and if this model
benefits Democrats and Republicans are
gonna say we're not in so have we
already modeled it out to know which
party this benefits and who it doesn't
you know what I'm asking right I do know
exactly what you're asking so you notice
that we are not proposing gerrymandering
reform okay that you mentioned that
before Elbridge Gerry and everything so
not to get deep into that but one of the
reasons that we don't work on that is
it's not necessary because final five
voting takes care of it but b-because
gerrymandering informed if you fix that
right now actually it would likely in
Congress accrue more to the benefit of
Democrats and that's the feeling meaning
it's a partisan reform it's a reform
that is a Trojan horse out gerrymander
is awful we should not have it okay it's
terrible but nothing we propose is like
that in order to be categorized as
achievable me required that it not be a
partisan change to the rules and as
proof of this essentially members of the
political industrial complex on both
sides don't want final five voting
except for as I mentioned these
courageous people who are saying it
needs to be different but members on
both sides hate this equally shall we
say because it affects both of them
theoretically you know even if he
equally and I also want to say that
remember
this whole who would win that's as if
looking at a past election saying who
would have won that election if we had
these rules but that's not a good
analysis because would you say that's
what they're gonna ask for they're not
gonna ask that but my point is if we had
these rules we wouldn't have had that
election because different people would
have been running in it the whole thing
would have played out differently even
the Republicans and Democrats who were
running would have been taking perhaps
different positions in this race and
remember yes everybody's gonna ask that
but it's still our job to say that's not
the important question we're not trying
to figure out who would have won in the
past we're trying to figure out what's
gonna happen in the future and we're
less concerned about who's winning and
more concerned about what they're doing
I mean I think it would lose me if you
approach me like that and I'm very
transparent with you here's why let me
because for me if somebody comes in and
says here's a model this is what we're
running both of you guys know what
modeling is you've done it more than
I've done it you you Michael you've done
billions of these and you ran a company
doing a quarter of a billion dollars per
year and so you've gone through to see
yourself and you've gone through
transaction you know for someone for
four and assume the people because
you're saying to powerful people are
what we do people right it's not the
politicians that we're the powerful ones
great the the P now but we can be now we
can't be and not now I agree with you if
you're talking to the people people need
simple stories to simplify to connect
with them not be typical you know
scholarly messages because the ones
you're over their head the message
doesn't go make America again easy it's
time for change easy I have a dream
easy all of that is easy some of this
stuff that becomes technical how do you
explain that to the average guy that
doesn't follow politics doesn't care for
politics doesn't trust politicians so if
somebody can say okay cool can we run
some models to see what it looks like I
would be so curious to know in a last
and and here's here's where I'm going
with this
you know how they say well the Barack
Obama costs this many seats and they
lost their jobs because of Barack Obama
or Barack Obama got so many people
reelected because he got re-elected and
your jobs are secure okay
Trump is gonna cost a house they lose
the house but he's got the Senate and
they got the Senate and he's going
around helping people to become the
Senate or replace or govern you know
that games gonna keep happening right
that's not going away
if this model ran and it showed that
that cannot happen you know it's it's
the voters may sit there and say you
know what I don't know if I really want
to look at it because there's not a
really model about it versus if there
was a model and I go through 80 names
and I say there's a 28% chance this
person wouldn't got re-elected we don't
know who would have but this Tony but
there's a 93% chance this would have
been the same is there a way to model
this out and I made it's a request
that's not possible is there a way to
model this out wouldn't be helpful
because you would be imposing a model it
wouldn't be valid is what I should say
it wouldn't be valid or helpful because
you'd be modeling something on from the
past with a set of new rules when people
would have played the game differently
it's like saying it's like saying who
would have won that basketball game if
we didn't have the 3-point shot rule who
would have won it
well people would have played the game
differently as soon as you put in at
3-point rule I don't know that much
about sports but don't you put in that
3-point rule the game changes the
players are different they play
differently so you can't say who would
have won that under different rules
because the people would have played it
differently if it took something else to
win it's not valid now here but your are
nonetheless totally right Patrick that
this conversation is not gonna win the
day so this conversation is about people
who are interested in the death and it's
about making the case to business
leaders and entrepreneurs who thought
everything was so rational but for
people who are going to vote for
example use referendums you really need
to you know be respectful of their time
and interest and talk about more choice
more voice and better results and if you
want to stop being disappointed with the
choices you see when you go in the
election booth in the you know in the
voting booth this is for you
if you want to stop being disappointed
with not feeling represented in Congress
and if you want to stop being
disappointed with the results this is
for you more choice more voice better
results so we make it about you know
people's experience who don't want to
spend the time to hear this whole thing
ya know I mean I'm just saying because
the the part I'm talking about is what
I'm talking technical modeling the other
part I'm talking I keep it simple stupid
where the whole world we're not in your
world we can sit I understand what
they're saying and make sense but what I
can say is I am all for it like I'm a
cheerleader
imagine a 6 5 to 40 guy in a miniskirt
jumping around and doing the dancing I
would do that for you even though it
wouldn't help much because I'd love to
see a third party come out and get some
kind of results so I appreciate that I'm
gonna go to Michael no you're gonna be a
cheerleader if you if you want me to
dress up and do you know cheering
dancing I'll even put a chance for you a
sink for you we would we would
definitely consider it
okay so somewhere in your viewers we
have some musical talent so we're asking
one of those viewers to make the chance
because that's not my talent and then
we'll put this all together and we'll
come back because seriously not true
we do need champions oh no I'm with you
and I'm with you it's one of the reasons
why I got excited about doing this
because this is a topic that it sounds
strange you asked me yesterday why are
you interested in politics like who
cares why is it you know why gets you a
why does this get you excited I think a
lot of the politicians right now are
bullying the voters and I'm not happy
about that and I'd like to see the voter
who is the product the customer was
always right this is why I trust
capitalism Richard Wolffe and I got into
a big heated debate which you saw a
couple clips of it and he had a
perspective of capitalism that I fully
disagree with because when there's
competition good but the only people
that one wonders competition is the
customer customer wins a ton and I think
we need more competition today and I'd
love to see that happen let's say we
entry and this is the last thing and
then I know you're Michael and I'm gonna
grass well Michael takes it from here
but we introduce a new term in our book
free-market politics a politics which
delivers the what healthy free markets
deliver innovation results
accountability that's catchy that makes
sense to me
free-market politics makes so much sense
to me oh my gosh that makes so much
sense to me I love it too I absolutely
love it the best of what the free
markets should deliver I love it awesome
awesome now if you don't mind I'd like
to go to very serious question with
Michael which I think the entire
audience is thinking about right now
Michael this is a tough question so I'm
gonna go to you with a tough question I
noticed when I was talking to Kathryn
you were eating something where those
jelly beans you were eating M&Ms mmm I
thought I had him I was trying to catch
him every time I said it looks like it
was blue but what is blue it wasn't
jelly man so if the audience is
wondering its Eminem's we're gonna put
the link below for those who guess I
want to go buy M&Ms this is not
sponsored by Eminem by the way just so
happens he loves M&Ms okay so Michael
let's go to you here's one of my
challenges and I think one of the issues
and by the way we're going to go into a
little bit business as well if you don't
mind because the audience kind of wants
to know some of the issues that we're
facing today and you're the best person
to talk about this so we'll spend some
of the time on business and we'll go
from there so Michael might my my
challenge is when I went to OPM I want
to OPM
and the content amazing I learned so
much by everybody that was there I mean
the teachers were so helpful everybody
was so helpful
Lawrence Cortes fired a hell out of me
when I came back to seeing how he thinks
and what he did with the company and now
he's at a completely different place I
think he's with gee I don't know if he's
with gee
or not I think he left me is with you
you know and and and just talking to the
other guys that were there as
entrepreneurs one of the days Hillary
Clinton and Trump were debating so you
can kind of see what season I was there
and they had the chow hall you know
where the chow hall is by the OPM right
by the ground and so we have were in
there there's about four or five hundred
of us that were sitting and watching the
teachers came out a lot of the people
came out and they're watching I'm
sitting on the outside okay as a person
that's voted on the left and the right
and I went from being a Democrat who was
a fan of Clinton bill then I went to
Republican because I was a fan of
capitalism then I go to being a
registered independent okay I'm on the
outside I'm kind of watching everybody
and the first thing on my mind is what
economy because that's what affects my
kids my family Mike you know my business
is what I do I was flabbergasted to see
how many people I didn't see one person
in that room for Trump literally three
four hundred people there 100% of people
were all team Hillary and they couldn't
stand anything Trump said now Trump is
obviously a very a controversial figure
we can agree you know I don't think
we've had a person that goes after
people the way he does ever in politics
as a president Twitter all this other
stuff how does a university like Harvard
have so much leanings politically on one
side on the left where somebody like me
who has three kids I want to teach these
guys well and I grew up in Iran and the
University I see as Harvard it's like
the place you want to have your kids go
through and we're talking about the five
stages you know first its policies you
know it's if candidate I got behind
which she got behind Obama then it was
policies than it was culture then it was
independent candidate then it was system
you know all of that stuff sometimes the
the voters and and and people out there
don't trust the kind of influence
universities are having over our kids
that we trust to send to a school to pay
50 to 70 grand a year for four years
knowing they're going to come out not
like in certain
policies and being pushed away from
capitalism what role do you think
universities and professors are playing
in to current policies and politics that
we have in America well I wish we could
play a very important role and I think
we can play a positive role I don't I
think you're right now I think right now
universities are sort of anti politics
you don't talk about politics and if you
do it's very liberal you know and that's
kind of the and that's and that's
familiy because of the faculty and the
nature of faculty and the kind of people
they are and their seniority and so
forth I think in our business school we
have a lot of people here that really
are very much about markets and very
much about capitalism but other parts of
the university that's viewed with some
suspicion as you know capitalism is not
is not really well-liked right now in
this moment in history and I I think
part of that is that there's too much
inequality and there's too many business
businesses that are prospering and
people are getting paid a lot of money
and they're doing well but the ordinary
citizen isn't doing so well and I think
if we want to get into the the covin
situation where we're in a and we're in
a really fundamental inflection point
now in capitalism because a lot of
companies given the kovat situation and
given the all the emotions that that is
triggered companies now believe they
have to make a difference they have to
make a positive difference they have had
a purpose they have to do good they have
to take care of their employees so we're
right now in the middle of what I hope
is a very powerful inflection point
around capitalism and how its viewed and
its ability to get support from citizens
and I think that's going to affect our
our politics as well over time if I
could just take a minute given the
discussion here with Catherine I just
want make sure that all of the viewers
understand a few additional points that
I think will help address some of the
questions you you asked so so the first
thing is we've already covered our
government is failing on economic policy
on social
policy we're failing we're not getting
anything done zero and we haven't in
decades and and and with inequality it's
going up all kinds of bad outcomes are
coming on in this country so why is this
and I think what what we all have to
understand is is the way the government
is structured now we have we have these
parties and these parties have
leadership and they have enormous clout
and enormous power the parties so for
example you're a young person when you
run for office and you say you get
elected and say that you don't follow
your party leaders advice on what to
vote for you're gone party leaders with
their ideology see they think ideology
they are on the right ideology or the
left ideology it's not about solutions
it's not about what gets the best job
done and it's it's literally about these
ideological partisan differences and the
the rights further all the conservative
stuff extreme or not and the left is for
the progressive stuff extreme for not
I've just been through that you know in
the in the campaign and you what that
understand is is this system is not
designed around getting things done it's
not designed about being practical doing
common-sense stuff having a rational
discussion making the best choices
it's not about compromise today the
parties don't compromise they will not
that's why we have no infrastructure
bill because there's certain aspects of
infrastructure and that the Democrats
like in certain aspects that the
Republicans like and they're not going
to get in they they don't want the other
party to get any benefit we we've had
lots of high-skilled immigration bills
to make immigration more rational in
America and both sides have put forward
those bills but in either case we
pass the bill because the other side
will block it because they don't like
this part of it because it doesn't fit
with their ideology so we've got to
understand now that that the people I'm
coming back to your point about the
people in the system and how they are
going to respond to all this and right
now the people that are members of
Congress and members of the Senate even
they are totally controlled by their
party leaders do you know that if you
put a bill forth in the house or the
Senate your party leader is going to
determine whether that bill even gets
considered they're going to determine
whether that bill even is voted on the
Speaker of the House can block even a
vote on a bill even if they know that
the majority of the house would have
passed that bill because they're
controlling the the agenda based on
ideology so we have a system now that is
really awful if you're a thinking member
of Congress or a thinking member in the
Senate and you want to do the right
thing you are living in a torture a
torturous system and so we believe that
if we can get the momentum going on on
some of these these these these
innovations that a lot of the people in
the system like the two people that
members of Congress that Katharine
talking about they're gonna actually
join in and they're gonna do it
carefully because they they want to get
you know excommunicated by their party
leaders but you probably know Eric
Cantor who was a Democratic leader who I
happened to know I've learned for a long
time as a terrific guy he got kicked out
by his party leaders because he was too
friendly he was too collegial he was too
much compromise he was talking to the
other side and he got checked out so I
think there's a there's a pent-up demand
for the smart capable people that we do
have in government to actually do the
right thing but right now the system is
just like a straightjacket that is
holding people for
doing doing the right things so I I'm
more optimistic also be clear your
viewers should know we have ranked
choice voting in the state of Maine the
citizens we have read Tori's voting on
the ballot in Massachusetts in November
and I'm feeling optimistic that that's
going to happen and it's all across the
country we're starting to see these
ballot initiatives we have in Florida
we're running in four there's a
nonpartisan primary legislation that is
looking good you know that that we might
get around getting around this partisan
primary system so to stop this happening
and what Katherine is saying is if we
can get this going in even a few states
it starts to have a ripple effect and so
I I mean I you know I I totally get your
modeling questions but I think we have
to tell we have to there's a story to
tell here about how we can actually get
this thing done and how the even is even
the party leaders are gonna bitterly
fight it it can still happen and you
know we we either so so that now let me
get back to your tear to your your
question about I think we're really
talking more about about capitalism and
about you know right and left let me let
me clear up for you so you kind of you
know kind of help you out is I'm a
capitalist I'm a die-hard capitalist I
escaped Iran to come here because I was
controlled
I was dictated I have fear manipulation
all of that I don't have a voice so what
did you remain he found a way to come
out here so as somebody was a capitalist
who has three kids that he's raising
with certain set of values and
principles and they read all the books
that are opposing books as well I mean
there's painting behind me these are
four characters behind me you may
recognize some of the faces I'm sitting
in a bank vault with Milton Friedman
right there in this bank vault and
they're debating two books one is
Communist Manifesto and the other one is
a carmine Rand's Atlas Shrugged I'm a
guy that likes capitalism and I grew up
in a family that they were constantly
fighting on both sides but the fear is
you know when when yours
saying it's not media and then we're
saying and media is not the concern
those are not the priority concerns our
mind is still not mature till about 25
26 years old you read this books there's
different ages some say 24 some say 28
you know what I'm talking about so Mike
while the brain is still being
established I'm sending them to and I'm
saying Michael take care of my boys and
my girls for four years please teach
them the right values and principles and
they're coming out slowly but surely not
like in capitalism like they used to
they're coming out slowly but surely
looking at rich people as bad people
they're coming out slowly but surely sin
I don't know you know it's unfair dad
that they're doing this and I'm not
talking about social issues that matter
that there is unfair and there is some
area of correcting an injustice I'm
purely talking economically what role is
that plain in the way we're voting today
because as you know it's easier to
persuade the younger audience than it is
to persuade a 40 year old audience
that's kind of been around the block and
there's younger audience the largest
generation bigger than baby boomers so
what role do you think college and
universities are playing in the way
we're voting and in the future of
politics in us well I think the the
narrative of capitalism and how its
perceived and what is being reinforced
in the university and what you know
professor types are saying and that's
what your Harvard Business School you
know because we're all about capitalism
here but we're not but we even here now
are talking a lot about well capitalism
isn't just making money capitalism is a
broader concept and it it's gonna be
good for society and we just can't think
about benefiting ourselves and our
company we've got a benefit we got a bet
that our consumers we've got to create a
good environment for our employees we've
got to make sure that the communities on
which we depend for our educated people
and the people we hire we got we've got
to make sure that our community is doing
well we you can't succeed as a
capitalist in a broken community that's
failing you know so I think I think
what's happening is the idea of
capitalism got to erode
to extreme it got too much about you
know let's you know let's let's just may
go up and up and up in terms of
valuation and salaries and stock options
and all these kind of things and this
tremendous gap in wealth between you
know folks in the business community and
and many others has created a lot of
resentment but III got to tell you I
think we have the greatest opportunity
right now that I've ever seen in my many
years doing this for capitalism to be is
repositioning itself and I think you
know you're probably familiar with you
know Larry Fink it and this movement
about corporate social purpose and a lot
of people you know when when that whole
idea was starting to get talking about
just rolling their eyes oh yeah that
sounds you know that sounds pretty soft
to me but I think what people are
starting to understand is that the way
business operates and the way capitalism
works can either benefit society and
improve communities and have ripple
effects that make things better or
capitalism can be very narrow and
selfish and self-interested and a few
people can win at the expense of
everybody else and so I think we what we
I think frankly we need capitalism we as
capitalist we need to do better we need
to have a different paradigm we need to
broaden our view of what our job is it's
not just about maximizing our in
comments about it's about a broader
understanding that you can't have a
successful company if you don't have a
successful society and right now partly
because of our political system we don't
have a successful civilized society we
have a lot of people that don't have
good health care we have a lot of people
that you know don't get good education
they don't have a chance we have a lot
of people that get you know
discriminated against just because of
you know in their race or their
background or whatever it is and you
know and we in capitalism haven't taken
any responsibility for any of that you
don't think so
I don't think we've taken very very many
how could you say that how could you say
that you know 40 40
5% of all jobs or by small business
owners these are people that risk their
salaries to go create a business and
sacrifice loose and we forget how many
them file bankruptcies are lost 10 years
of their lives have filed divorces and
ended up in bad relation all we think
about is what they do wrong we don't
think about the amount of sacrifices you
see I was speaking with a Cornell
University professor at an event and he
says the thing with capitalism that gets
a black eye is capitalism out you know
the collective but also not forgetting
the individual meaning we need Boeing I
agree with you on the collective side
but I think we're bashing the
individuals lately and I think we have
to be very careful because if if kids
grow up not admiring these guys they're
not gonna want to be these guys if kids
grow up just hiring rock stars and
superstars and Instagram models and all
these people that are out there they're
like I don't want to go be an
entrepreneur because they get hated by
everybody why would I want to be
somebody that's hated so I think I think
sometimes the the element of recognizing
the person that took the most risk we
don't tell those stories we only tell
the horror stories and it's unfortunate
and again I'm bringing it to you because
you may be the most influential person
in the world of business when it comes
down to Professor I admire you I study
you I'm a student of yours so I'm
talking to you as a guy that looks at
you and the things you write I read and
I devour so and I want to be able to
make sure that you know when my kids
decide to go through a program I know
they're gonna get recognition to say son
it's okay go create a good idea do
better job unity and it's okay so
sometimes I see that language engine
because I also think someone like you
and again you can say path you're so
full of it you're wrong I also think
somebody like you because where you've
been you got your degrees both from
Harvard I think both of them you got
from Harvard not not not all three of
them two of them is from bright you know
you're you're somebody that's also in
that environment for so much that you
get pressured and you eventually are
like man maybe maybe they're right and
maybe you're getting pressure to you
know forget about the original Michael
Porter that was so inspired by kind of
sports and golf and competition and how
much sports and competition can
help for business and life and all this
other stuff so I just I'm just putting
it in your ear to not forget the
individual yeah well I get that but I
and again I can tell you I'm the most
card-carrying capitalist on the face of
the earth you know that's what I do
I believe in it I believe in competition
and frankly I believe in smaller
businesses and smaller companies but
what we've had is too many of our big
companies have you know used their cloud
or their power to distort the system and
and and to make things work I mean we
have companies now that are that are
lobbying for getting their merger deals
through the Department of Justice by
giving them a lot of money for lobbying
you know and so I think I think we have
we've got to recalibrate what good
capitalism looks likely and particularly
among the bigger companies the small
business people are heroes
there's just no doubt about it and they
they're almost inherently benefiting
their community because they care about
the neighbors in the business next door
and they care about making sure that the
public services are good and they have a
tremendous powerful effect what I worry
about is the you know kind of at least
some subset of the major major
corporations are I've been looking at
their role too narrowly and and we need
open up and that's all I'm saying I'm
not I'm not saying anything more than
that I think that's the best transition
to ask you a question about what
happened with Hertz I'm sure you saw it
where sixteen point three million
dollars of bonuses they paid to three
hundred thirty of their executives with
$600,000 bonus to the new CEO that just
got a hired a month ago right before
filing bankruptcy and they're in debt
nineteen point eight billion dollars
well how do you process that when you
hear something like that taking place
it's it's it's it's a little bit like
the party leaders and it's the people at
the top are out for themselves and they
don't feel that they have a
responsibility for their own work force
and the success of their company and the
communities in which they're operating
and all the vendors that are supplying
them that depend on them it's just a
narrow somewhat
you know very narrow view of what the
goal is and what is success and I think
we have to open that up a little bit and
there's lots of lots of bad examples
like that that I've encountered over the
years and but there's nothing that can
do more good and benefit more people
than capitalism if we get it right
companies who have epic effects on
society they can change everything they
can you know but but we have to I think
broaden a little bit our responsibility
because part of it is because government
is failing if we have great schools if
we had good infrastructure if we had
people good health care that wasn't too
expensive and if we didn't have a lot of
discrimination if our government wasn't
mistreating minorities you know if all
that wasn't going on maybe you know we
wouldn't but I think we are in a society
now where business has to take more
responsibility for some of these things
that government is failing to do now
Katherine and I believe strongly we got
a fixed government you know we got to
fix the system and we got it we got to
be honest that the system is not working
and we got to be honest that we can't
just play the game the way they've
created it I mean one of the things that
Katherine said that I just want your
viewers everybody to know this for how
government works and how happen how the
policy political system works they're
all created by the parties they're not
in the Constitution the Constitution
didn't say if the parties said oh this
would be good for us because we do this
it'll be impossible for a new competitor
to come in so so this system has been
has been perverted and it was our
greatest strength you know we had this
amazing effective democracy for so many
years and now we don't and but we got to
take it on and take it on you have to
understand the bitter reality of what it
really is and what it's become and and
you know our passion in life is to is to
get people to understand what it is and
therefore we think a lot of Americans
will want to get on this particular path
final questions here before we wrap up
so current a lot of people are asking me
questions st. panel what's going to
with the airline industry you've spoken
about the airline many many times and at
a big profit margin business you know
people get into because it's kind of
sexy but they're getting camera the
rental car business is getting hammered
or hotels are getting hammered
entertainment industry is getting
hammered Las Vegas is getting hammered
so many different industries are getting
hammered but some what I'm also doing
very good you know really well what do
you see happening over the next 3 6 12
months and are some industries
completely gonna have to change the way
they do business or are we gonna go back
to business as usual well I don't think
I think I think we're gonna see a change
in how we do business because what's
happening is the nature of competition
is changing the nature industry
structure is evolving you know so
companies are the channels are changing
the suppliers and supply chain is
changing there's a lot going on that is
really gonna cause a lot of companies
have to modify their strategy you know
so far most of the responsive business
to Coe bid has been very tactical you
know we got to follow the rules we have
to work at home we have to make sure
everybody's safe and that was the place
to start but what we're going to see
over time is businesses are changing so
let's take one example of the hakkoda
lawn and garden business which I happen
to know very well okay that's booming
why because in this world that we're
living in now and with people are often
where at home they want they want to
work in their yard they want to have a
vegetable garden bathe there they want
to plant stuff and unify their home and
that's one of those industries that
that's that's booming and despite the
the overall crisis we see we see other
industries like that so some industries
are going to benefit by the needs that
are changing other industries are going
to be threatened by it and and the
question is so we're gonna have a
different economy when this is over but
we're going to go back to transportation
eventually people are going to travel
again we're gonna we're gonna
tell us are gonna have have a roll but
you know how do you migrate you know in
this trough how do these organizations
migrate and survive their way through
and and the ones that are lucky enough
how do they take advantage of the
opportunity that's been created and and
one of the things that everybody you
know should know is whatever business
you're in you've got to think about the
influence of this digital technology
okay so instead of going to a workout
studio now you can just do the workout
at home you know on video you know and
there's a lot of products and services
that are now being delivered and take a
different form and this digital
revolution has gotten to the point now
where it's really starting to change
competition and it's not-me part of your
strategy and you can't just say oh no we
just do it the traditional way so I I
think that we're having a real
structural change in the economy it's
not that it's always going to be new and
it's never going to go back a lot of
things are going to read are gonna you
know come back but many things are gonna
change as well so the idea that we have
a supply chain in China we're not doing
that anymore you know people are not
sourcing in China because they don't
want to get cut off they want to get
subject to you know a pandemic they want
their suppliers closer to home so we're
seeing all kinds of interesting trends
in terms of the competition and so every
CEO now has to look at a fundamental
level at their business how's my
business changing how do my customers
what do they want now how are they
evolving what are their needs what can
they afford you know how do i how do i
you know construct my supply chain you
know in in this world you know that were
that is going to be the world of the
future so I think this is a this is a
really interesting moment for strategy
and and we're seeing the companies that
are going to do really really well
they're the ones that can you know that
can flip that can understand that this
this is not just a
you know short-term crisis it's it's
it's it's a sign that industry
competition is changing and now they
have to adjust it one of the fascinating
articles as examples is Best Buy and on
you know Best Buy but you know they're a
company that you know they sold you know
electronic goods in in in source and
they figured out that people can buy the
same electronics you know on Amazon so
they turn themselves into a service
company and they were the ones that can
actually help you fix the TV you know or
make sure it was installed properly it
out great approach they took see it's
it's an amazing example and how if
you're seeing how the world is changing
and if you understand competition how
you can actually pivot to a whole
different competitive positioning so I
mean I know your your company that well
but be fascinating to think about with
what does this mean how can we take
advantage of this you know to to be even
better in in in the next next stage of
the economy you know capitalism is is
gonna find a way but it's good it's
gonna test a lot of industries that are
so used to the way things are done that
they'll have a hard time see oh no we
don't want to deliver this way anymore
you know we do it this way and what's
what's stressful now is you're having it
you having to take fairly radical
changes in how you do business because
of the circumstances some of them are
short term some of them are going to be
long term do you do you think commercial
real estate is over with like you think
commercial real estate is gonna take a
massive hit because of a zoom growing
from what it was to now forty eight
billion dollar company a lot of
companies were forced to adjust to zoom
yeah I think I think it's gonna take I
think it's gonna go it's gonna take a
somewhat of a decline but at least my
perception and I talk to a lot of
companies about this is it's actually
not that efficient for everybody to work
at home and just be out great it's
frustrating and and I think first of all
it's not a human thing people people
want to be with other humans and they
want to talk and they want to solve
problems together and
want to do it collegially so I think but
I do believe that there's a lot of trips
at meetings that we don't need to have
and there's a lot of things that we can
do sort of more surgically using this
technology but I so I would if I was in
real estate I'd be rethinking my
strategy I wouldn't think I'm going away
I would be rethinking how to be real
estate honey what kind of real estate
you know configurations what kind of
services I want to offer I wouldn't be
thinking about you know I'm done
so is there if you were a start-up
entrepreneur right now is there an
industry that you would say this looks
very sexy and is there something you
would say I wouldn't touch that at all
right now
well you know Michael Porter everybody
wants to know yeah that's that's a very
a very hard question I would say that
the whole luxury goods space is is going
to have a cloud over it for some time
and we'll see what happens but I think
the idea of being conspicuous and
spending huge amounts on these things I
think that we're in a different era now
I think people are going to be much more
cautious and they're going to be much
more you know thoughtful and how they
spend their money and what they spend it
on and things like that so I would say
the luxury good space has been a real
hot space you know you can those are
great companies they have massive
valuations but I think that I think
that's gonna change but I think you know
it's funny stuff relate to the home
cooking gardening stuff like that I
think is thriving interesting you know
the Sherwin Williams company is one of
the great paint company you know it's
the page is booming people are painting
their rooms they're painting their
houses and and that's because they've
been at home they've they've come to
really treasure their home and that's a
different mindset you know and so I
think it there's this is a fascinating
time because this is heaven for me you
know industry industry it's a whole
different game it's changing what do we
do
are we adjusted this what's long term
what's short term what's temporary
what's permanent and every CEO and every
leader is going to have to
think this through and and it varies
dramatically across industries and still
on uncertainty you know we still don't
know quite when this you know coded
thing is going to get under control so
anyway are you optimistic I'm optimistic
I really am I I don't think that I think
in this era a technology that is
available we we will find medical
science solutions to this problem and
it's not going to require people wearing
a mask for the rest of their life I
think we're going to be able to not do
that eventually but and but are this is
an example where our government failed
us because we the response to this
crisis has been so and so political and
so you know partisan and and I think I
think we've we sent ourselves back in
how this has been dealt with and that's
you know I particularly concerned about
the federal level where we just weren't
organized and we didn't get testing
online and we didn't really manage this
well and I think that's partly because
of the political system we're in and the
fact that too many people in government
roles today our party loyalists and you
know that were that got a job because
they were a trusted party loyalist so so
I think I think the political system is
partly explaining some of the challenges
we've had here but I think we'll get
through it and I think we've got a lot
of medical science it's just a lot of
energy going on now in medical science
and I think we're gonna see some really
terrific progress over the next you know
six months or a year so hopefully it'll
be sooner a lot of it all good well
Katherine I'll give you a final thoughts
here before we wrap up the audience's
listen to you even to Michael what are
your final thoughts what should we be
thinking about to finish this interview
yeah thanks Pat first I'm thinking I
love long-form interview that's what I'm
thinking thank you for signing all this
time with us how are we gonna tell this
story in five minutes on another media
platform we're gonna say free-market
politics
but what I what I want to leave the the
viewers with and is you know this our
book to her so you could say we're
trying to sell books but actually we
only care about selling books because we
want people to buy in to the change that
we need and then we want them to take
action so I definitely invite people to
buy the book and I invite people to get
in touch with us and to think about
being the leaders in their state to make
these changes happen you know I'll close
with this quote I'm a Wisconsin girl and
one of the leaders in the press of arrow
was from Wisconsin Bob LaFollette and he
said America is not made but is in the
making and that there's an ending
struggle to keep government
representative men must be aggressive
for what is right if government is to be
saved from those who are aggressive for
what is wrong and now is the time for
the entrepreneurial spirit that has led
to so much progress globally to come
back to our politics and it is time for
people who watch your program who have
that kind of spirit to say we can also
make a difference in our politics so
take some part of attention that has
been given to business or policy and
focus it like a laser on the system of
our politics and then I join Michael in
this optimistic spirit of where we're
gonna go to thank you for having us
we're just thrilled super fun it's been
a blast Michael Katherine thank you so
much for taking the time we're gonna
leave all the links below of all the
articles whatever you send us Katherine
and Michael we're gonna put it below any
of the things that we talked about as
well as if you have an order to
go order the book I think it's coming I
said June 23rd or or exactly but
pre-orders are now pre-orders are now so
go go pre-order your book nowadays these
printers are delaying so if you don't
pre-order early they may not ship your
copy till July make sure you order your
copy and once again gang thank you so
much for coming on being a guest michael
captain thank you that's right what a
pleasure do you think we're ready for
third party what do you think yes no if
you do come and ballon what would that
party look like and what would they
stand for I'm actually curious to know
what you think about this obviously you
know having Katherine Gail and Michael
Porter coming from their world and what
they've done they gave their perspective
but I want to hear from you now and as
well as on top of that if you enjoyed
this interview there's two other
interviews I want I'd want you to watch
one and one of them is with a nine year
Federal Reserve of Dallas advisor Daniel
de Martino booth who was on value Tim
and I think her interview was picked up
by news all over the world got 20
million views total all over the world
if you've not watched this interview to
a very very deep interview click here to
watch that interview with Daniel
DiMartino booth or Ray Dalio which we
discussed China a little bit of politics
views different ways of looking at
finance different ways of looking at
politics and so either one of these if
you've not watched them click on them to
watch them and if you've not subscribed
to the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody take care bye-bye
you
[Music]